Now that we factored and found our vertical asymptote, let's use long division
just like we did in the last lesson, to find the horizontal asymptote of this
function. First though, I'm going to need to multiply the numerator out again,
so that I have something in a form that I can divide with. Okay, so now I have
that T equals 0.966x squared plus 9.66x divided by 11x plus 50. Let's use long
division to carry out this division that we see in the fraction. So here I've
written out our division in long division form. If we solve this long division
problem, what is the first term of our answer going to look like? Is it going
to be some coefficient times x. Will it be a constant? Will it be a fraction
with a denominator of 11x plus 50? Or, will it not be anything because you
refuse to do anymore long division at all.